ecco qua bacio bravo è bravo bravo
pechino
spenta la luce mi è sembrato di sentire
un rumore in giardino
berlino la vedi anche con quella strana
luce vedi anche tu quella luce che cos'è
è scomparsa è visto perché è saltata
alla luce proviamo ad accendere la
lampada vieni merli e lampada noce
berliocchi ricordato che ho messo la mia
fila non si vede niente ha detto qualche
cassetto si ammassava se non sbaglio
eccola per fortuna avevo questa pila fa
in camera
berlino tu stai bene hai visto cosa cena
fuori
andiamo a vedere giardino che ci arrivo
c'è qualcosa di sotto la porta
ho io
vengo dalle tenebre per rubare la luce
riuscirai a trovare qualcosa per
fermarmi e vivrai anche tu nelle tenebre
per sempre ha firmato mb
che cosa vuol dire mb tmb mister va
baule mister bauli miss oppure non è
mister magari e mastro
perché no
se nessuno se n'è uno berlino per
fortuna ci sei tu vuò con me che mi
protegge rischio di rumori ma ci sono
film forse devo spegnere una pila vedere
se si avvicino qualcosa vediamo
per l'elettricità source è destinato a
trovare ancora cosa che si illumina al
buio senza parte vivere senza
elettricità force fino alla sconfitta
io parlata in ogni fase si deve fare una
parta da virgilio attivo beh se lo dici
tu quando tempo perché stanno peggio
oddio che vuol dire passo successo
adesso quindi
spunta minuti in frigo allontanati per
dio pericoloso torniamo in camera
berlino berlino fini ha capito cosa ha
detto dovremo trovare qualcosa che si
illumini senza elettricità e senza pile
perché può sempre andare dai cattivi
ok ragazzi avete sentito una nuova
avventura per anita e merlino ma bene
come funziona questa volta è personaggio
strano che vuole rubare ma che ha già
rubato l'elettricità sono costretto a
usare questa ha detto che devo trovare
qualcosa che si illumini senza
l'elettricità e quindi ho già pensato
alla pila ma poi ha detto anche le
batterie
quindi secondo te merlino cosa può
essere o berlino
vorrei tanto che tu potessi parlare
berlino sta fiutando qualcosa a voi cosa
viene in mente
provate a scriverlo nei commenti mi
raccomando lasciate un mi piace se
volete altre challenge al buio per ci
sarebbero tipo quella sorta di stickers
che si attaccano che si illuminano al
buio
basta ricaricarli con un po di luce
tri cavo luce del sole però non ho
nessuno di quegli stickers oppure ci
sono anche quelle figurine quelle
statuette che si illuminano al buio ma
non ho neanche nessuna di quelle o una
cosa che si illumina al buio senza
elettricità e senza batterie la colla
proverò a creare lo slime che si
illumina al buio e portarlo da questo
signor mb che non ha voluto dirmi il suo
vero nome iniziamo la nostra ricerca
io il mirino sulla faremo anche questa
volta vediamo chi ha sicuramente più
difficile
quella che fu la semina tantissimo
l'abbiamo salvata subito finché non
trova tutti gli altri
ho paura che dovrebbe uscire fuori
l'apparente ragazzi maturava lenta e qui
visto che cosa ci fai qua c'è più cari
certo
accendere antiqua parla bassa fosse per
non farmi sentire da lui ma spero che
come mi sentite o non sa quanto tempo ci
mette 4 pari
l'associazione barletti di carburante se
c'è qualcosa qua
l'harley l'unesco per dario dove
cercarli su berlino sta cercando gli
ingredienti dobbiamo seguirlo era giù lo
vedete
ma medici si stanno vicino d altra parte
[Applauso]
questo è un gioco di merlino ragazzi non
trovo gli altri ingredienti marino sta
pagando forse ha visto qualcosa è vero
che c'è marino più bassi non stavo
abbaiando a quel coso ed è scappato
merlino e sempre nella mia guardia del
corpo comunque non riesco a trovare
niente perché ovviamente c'è troppo buio
e non c'è un bel niente
7 proveniente in più abbastanza pauroso
con fuori di notte mi chiamo se c'è
qualcosa in questo è vero io da padre
pio carburato ragazzi manca solo la
soluzione per l'ente non so dove sia
finito quel covo su si no
hai trovato qualcosa che mi trovato
qualcosa
berlino sta continuando a cercare a
fiutare la tiriamo la nostra ricerca
inquietante fuori in giardino al buio
frattempo faccia queste cose qua sopra
altrimenti non riesco a tenere la pila
più tutti gli ingredienti
quindi
[Musica]
e ancora più difficile se mi deve anche
inseguire nel frattempo c'è qualcosa qua
sopra il par le prendiamo subito
anzi credo ragazzi ho preso tutto ora
devo riuscire a rientrare dentro casa ok
che ripara parola o prendere tutti
questi ingredienti non riesco a tenere
tutto berlino berlino bravo pieni marino
entrare
per fortuna e ancora qualcosa proprio
scatenare tutto il varo a tirana sono
attualmente non pensavo che non avrei
mai trovato un bel niente al buio
il giardino è stato fatto tutto ok
ragazzi ho appoggiato latina io non so
nemmeno se funzionerà questo non far
sparire a lui come tutti gli altri
personaggi cattivi
però secondo me ha senso perché questo
slide che si illumina al buio si
illumina senza elettricità e senza
batteria
quindi per forza questo
[Musica]
le linee qua sotto che controlla il mio
fedele aiutante guardate il corpo
miglioramento e bicarbonato telenostra
controllato tutto
nb scrivete nei commenti secondo voi per
cosa sta mb cosa potrebbe voler dire
scoliamo spero che poi si illumina al
buio altrimenti è stato inutile ecco
fatto ragazzina slime pronto non so se
restava parlo bene
eccolo qua ma ora dobbiamo fare la prova
e vedere se si illumina veramente al
buio speriamo pronti wow si illumina
tantissimo direi che abbiamo risolto
l'indovinello del cattivo perché si
illumina un sacco cordate fa anche luce
sulla mia faccia però non ha né
elettricità né batterie
wow guardavate la lizza diventata lo fa
con lo storico ma vabbè ora torniamo nel
corridoio dove abbiamo incontrato per la
prima volta mb
vediamo che cosa dirà del nostro super
tra remo e luminoso
ciao destino non c'è nessun mb o quello
che richiede vmb perché non si fa vedere
mb guardo quello che richiede v forse
devo spegnere la pila così competere
bene che questo plan si illumina al buio
mb guarda così io volevo solo l'aspetto
momento non appoggio la pila è una volta
da dirti una cosa volevo dirti che ho
creato quello che chiede v questo è uno
slang che si illumina come puoi vedere
prima ma c'è bisogno di tempi cd così
tanto sei comunque si illumina non ha né
elettricità né batterie estate se vuoi
puoi prenderlo se non si 3d
nonno battaglia una battaglia quindi ci
saranno altre sfide molto però non sono
di certo uno stinco assalto la prossima
volta
una volta scoperto torino berlino fra i
morlino ce l'abbiamo fatta abbiamo
sconfitto mb che non so ancora per
questa e abbiamo vinto questo challenge
anche se ha detto che tornerà il saranno
volevi difficili le altre ma voi
lasciate un bel mi piace se questo video
rai su 6 40 mila mi piace ci sarà
un'altra challenge molto paurosa e ora
vi lascio qua 4 caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
[Musica]